what lessons did you take away from
going to afm and were there any things
in hindsight that you wish you know well
what one of the the lessons I learned in
the AFM and you know what it's not I
don't particularly agree with this
philosophy but it's something I did
learn but I don't want but I'm going to
the caveat here is that I don't
necessary with this every distribution
company out there always asked well
who's the talent in the film so and it
didn't really matter if it was you know
an be less actor or see less doctor or
an a-list actor it even if they were
then there for like you know 30 seconds
they just wanted somebody attached to
the film so when you're out there doing
a project and if you can grab on to like
an a-lister or B Lister who will come
into your project for just like you know
even like a few minutes to the
distributor's that makes a big
difference or if you're dealing with a
finite budget and you can't allocate
some funds to hire talent that can bring
attention to your project then the
distributor's do take notice my personal
philosophy on filmmaking is if you if
you as an independent filmmaker you you
have very limited budget and I like to
put all my funding into the story and
hiring like excellent actors and talent
but it doesn't they don't have to have
been on you know NBC for five years or
had like you know a couple of big movies
or something because what I'm trying to
do is tell a story a compelling story
and I guess I I go into the project my
philosophy is going into the project in
completing a film and hopefully people
will find it entertaining but the thing
I learned from the AFM is that you
should go into a film thinking well how
am I going to sell it in the end so
that's the big take-home message like if
you want to continue in
business unless you've hit a home run on
your first film and you've got extra
funds to knock out a couple more films
you got to go into it thinking what's
your endgame what's your exit strategy
and sometimes as a creative person you
you sort of have to take a backseat and
be business minded and save yourself
okay well maybe I can't do this
excellent action sequence for 30 grand
over three days but I'd give this 30
grand to this great actor to come in for
two days so I can put him on the face of
my DVD cover so so those are the kind of
you know things you you learn at the AFM
at the business of it that's a you learn
it well when you're over there because
there weren't who is in the film
was attached so
you